President Trump claims a historic number
of achievements in his first hundred
days in office most of them are in the
form of executive actions that do not
need a vote in Congress by the end of
today the president will have signed 30
executive orders that is more than any
president in his first hundred days
since Harry Truman 72 years ago
chip Reid looks at the impact of all
these orders chip good morning good
morning in the absence of any major
legislation the White House claims the
first 100 days have been a success in
large part because of the president's
use of executive orders in fact in the
past week alone he has had for signing
ceremonies it's one of the most common
images of Donald Trump's young
presidency do we have the executive
order place the signing of an executive
order you know what it says right you're
going back to work many of the orders
he's signed are aimed at overriding
Obama era reforms like climate change
efforts regulation of the financial
industry and the designation of federal
parks and lands others have been so
drastic in scope that they spurred
nationwide protests during his first
week in office the President signed an
order restricting immigration from seven
muslim-majority nations that was blocked
by the courts the president still says
he will fight as I said we'll see him in
the Supreme Court as a candidate mr.
Trump lambasted then President Obama for
using his executive power I've got a pen
and I've got a phone though mr. Obama
signed 13 fewer in his first 100 days
he's given up on the process and he just
goes inside the executive orders and
everything executive orders are usually
used by presidents when they face
gridlock in Congress but Republicans now
control both houses I think he's trying
to show action President Obama's former
chief of staff Bill Daley says the
president is trying to quickly make good
on some campaign promise real progress
real change has to be done by the two
branches of government legislative
branch and the executive branch working
together to pass laws that fundamentally
change things
IRA flesh or press secretary to george w
bush at the beginning of his presidency
says voters elected mr. trump in part to
undo the last eight years
when many ways Barack Obama governed by
executive order when you govern by
executive order you can be uncovered by
executive order and that's what Donald
Trump has done the White House says the
2016 election was a mandate for change
and they say the president's aggressive
use of executive orders shows he's
taking that mandate very seriously
Gail all right chip thank you